[Music]
today's
a new day it is not the morning though
even though i'm still in my pjs because
hey it's
we're in a pandemic we get to be in our
pjs all day every day don't judge me
don't judge us if you can eat breakfast
all day if all these
different breakfast places can do
breakfast all day we can do pajamas all
day
exactly and no makeup don't judge me
yeah i'm not doing my hair and bad hair
every day
yeah hat all day but at least you're not
in pjs
well i didn't go outside i went to the
post office recently uh like a couple
hours ago actually
yeah you know gotta look nice for the
post office
we gotta impress huh just kidding post
office
guy behind the counter i'm just kidding
but anyway how are you guys we're great
we've been doing well what do you think
of my new arrangement of the pillows i
actually fixed them up just for you guys
because
we took away those like prickly pad
thingies
that we put on for this guy let mommy
what the thing about zoe recently he's
been doing this thing which is so weird
but at night he started
like yelling he's like meowing but like
really annoyingly and like
from his gut he's like and then so i
googled it
i'm like oh my gosh and it's so funny
because the range is like
from like kidney disease to he's just
bored
so we ended up uh we got this like
little cat toy and so now we just play
with him at night
and that seems to be doing the trick so
i don't think it's kidney disease
i'll take boredom over cancer any day
yeah
exactly i mean we don't want the worst
stuff to happen
but yeah that's just a little update on
zoe's behavior recently
i got a package today and it was from
okay i gotta i gotta tell you the truth
it wasn't today i actually got this
package
quite some time ago and it's from our
very good friend nancy from hawaii she
sent us over
a whole bunch of delicious hawaiian
snacks
look at all this baking powder seedless
cream peach plum
sour strawberry strips leaking baby
bears
some leeking watermelon jalpia
can i try can i try i i forgot how to
say this
albia alpia ling
mango we talked a few months ago
and we said that we're going to be doing
a little snack exchange because she
really wanted some mexican
snacks especially the pelon one that you
push
and then it's like all this delicious
yumminess that comes out of it they
don't have mexican snacks in hawaii so i
was like yes girlfriend
we're gonna do a snack exchange
[Music]
and she sent me her box and i took so
long to send her hers literally just
today we sent it
oh yeah that's why i was at the post
office oh
i'm so bad i have no excuse i'm so bad
at that
um and i've been like telling her i'm so
sorry i'm gonna send it to you that's
why i said like i got the package today
because i told her
i'm not gonna open the package until i
send this to you like i i'm refusing to
enjoy the delicious snacks you sent me
until
i'm able to return the favor so finally
today we did it
and i've been enjoying those delicious
watermelon slices they're so good
but anyway back to what i wanted to talk
about
so today is jk newsday you guys know
what that means
we are looking for news articles
studying them and
preparing for our jk news marathon
so we changed the way that we filmed jk
news now
in the past they used to be every single
thursday we have an entire day of
filming
but now ever since the pandemic hit now
we take these like
two week breaks so it's like one week we
do
thursday friday saturday filming three
days in a row
and then casey and i now it's we've kind
of settled into a more
routine schedule where i host thursday
he hosts friday and i host saturday
now we're like we're the the two main
hosts pretty much he takes over on
friday because i'm like dude i can't do
hosting three days in a row that's
it's intense so coming off the bench
yeah so then our friday james i'm
i don't know the bench team
but yeah so like on friday i take that
day and in between takes
i'm like studying and preparing to host
for saturday
so that's the reason why we came up with
this like new way of doing things
kuzma that's a that's a bench player oh
i was like
what they were saying something like
it's kismet
or something it was chilling because i
just watched the entire finals i was
like i know this team
okay sorry it's okay with all this
studying going on today
it actually made me want to talk about
our sponsor for this video
so thanks to blinkist app
for sponsoring this video have you guys
heard of blinkist i never heard of it
and then so when they hit us up and
they're like hey you guys down a partner
i was like what is this
all about so what it is is they have
condensed over 3 000
non-fiction books and they put them in
like short 15-minute segments
so in like little blink where you can
actually absorb
the information of the book so it's kind
of like summarizing a book and you can
either listen to it or
just read the blinks it's super
convenient so quick to just
get a summary of the book and really get
the whole gist of it especially
when you're like short on time or even
like when you're doing your makeup or
doing laundry because actually i was
listening to it while i was doing
laundry earlier
i was listening to jordan peterson's 12
rules for life and they condensed that
book really well i actually wanted to
see
how else they condense other books so i
kind of compared it to a book that i
have already read
so i compared eckhart tolle's a new
earth
awakening i think it's the name a new
earth and
i thought they did a really good job so
i personally
am loving blinkist and i have a
membership now so i'm going to be
consuming all the books i can and just
trying to
grasp whatever knowledge i can because
you know you can never learn too much
these days
so for the first 100 people to go to
blinkist.com
tiffin case you guys will get unlimited
access to blinkist
for one whole week for free and
if you decide to keep the full
membership you'll get 25
off i'm pretty sure you guys are gonna
love it because i have a full membership
now i actually got addicted i'm so
excited to see what other books i could
dive into
and absorb the knowledge because you can
never learn too much these days
i have absolutely loved this so once
again go to blinkist.com
tiffincase for the first 100 people to
click on that link
you will get unlimited access for one
whole week for free
25 off of full membership enjoy let me
know what you guys think so where are we
at with our jk news articles
15 articles and i'm still looking for
new stuff but it's kind of a slow
week i mean the fun escapist articles
not the not the sad stuff in the world
i know everyone else covers that stuff
and we don't want to do that as much
yeah we don't yeah it's just too
depressing we
try to get what is it 16 articles
per shoot day so 16 times 3
you do the math because i can't do it me
neither but for the entire day though
is 20 videos that we film every day so
that's
pretty much what we have to prep for
there's four videos
every day that we don't necessarily have
to prep for because they're just off the
record type of videos
or like two off the records and then two
for our patreon viewers
we've got 15 out of 20 down because we
we include the four
in the count just so it feels like we
got more done oh only
one then what no it's 15 out of 20. we
still need five
all right yeah see i can mess a little
bit simple math i
really can't have oh did we show them
the backyard
yeah because i did the plants and stuff
but yeah what do you think what do you
think of the plants and stuff it really
gives you some life huh
it totally does i really like it a lot
you know what i like wait for it to grow
more
true you know what i like the most about
it is that if you look in here
the primary colors you see what are the
main colors you see blue
red white blue i'll take the blue and
red
uh-huh black we come here we got blue
and red here and then look out the
window what do you got going on blue and
red and white
yeah the white countertops yeah i really
like i really like how cohesive we've
made the backyard yeah
with this living room in our kitchen too
wait till i stencil this baby it's gonna
be so cool
okay so i didn't tell you guys but i
actually
learned how to photoshop just so i can
photoshop
the stenciling on the backyard in the
front yard i've never seen tiff
so adamant about learning something like
something that she knew nothing about
and then
in a matter of like i have to say like
two hours it became like a pro
yeah you're moving so fast and i was
like what
what you if you just apply yourself to
photoshop you can do that
yes okay well the thing is the thing
that you got to learn about me is that
i love
tedious work annoying repetitive work
i love that so much i've always said
that i'm like the perfect
um what's that called the conveyor belt
kind of
line work what is it anyway that thing
i'm like a perfect worker for that
this is the before of the front yard and
then
this is the after that i photoshopped of
the front yard
and i added black lines because my goal
is to add grout
in between the cement but once i went to
home depot and i talked to everybody
they were like
um it's gonna be way too hard for you to
avoid
coloring the grout so if you're trying
to paint like over it then just paint
over the whole thing
so i'm just gonna paint it so i'm saying
all this to get to the point of
ignore the black lines they're just
gonna be painted over anyway and the
reason why i decided to photoshop it is
because i wanted to play around with the
color
variations for the stenciling i just i
don't have an imagination
i needed to like see it in front of my
face and that's the reason why i was
determined to learn photoshop we already
actually bought all the paints
and the only reason why i haven't
started stenciling yet
is because we need to get
the guy who did the backyard back and
ask him to figure out how he's gonna
solve this problem
but a while back when we were washing
the entire backyard because there was a
lot of ash
from the fires and we were just like
cleaning it out we were vacuuming first
and then we like tried
rinsing it off but then as i'm rinsing
it off the entire backyard like there
were pockets of it that
just pulled up and it did not drain at
all
especially the corner where the
refrigerator is in the backyard
so i'm like dude that needs to be fixed
like i'm not going to be painting this
if that's still going to be pulling up
whenever it rains
and stuff that's really dangerous
because literally the refrigerator is
right there that's not a good thing
so that's the reason why i have not
started painting the backyard
i am so excited to see my photoshop
thing come to life and make it into a
reality
and then also i just kind of want to
finish the backyard already we still
need to put up the
string lights and put up the fake vine
stuff that i bought
and put up the projector screen that's
pretty much what's going on with the
backyard i'm out of breath man
you know before you start working out
you gotta be vlogging more it's part of
your
regimen all right it's like it's my
cardio
cardio and you work up to walking
outside then you'll walk
work up too oh man is that how out of
shape i am oh no
this is sad i am man ever since the
pandemic hit
i have not really moved i've had to
force like to like
force myself to get up and like work out
or like do stuff
and be a better man than i am it's hard
though it's hard there's no
you know what it made it easier to work
out and look nice whenever you had to be
in public
trust now that we don't have to be in
public as often it's like i guess i
don't have to do all that work the thing
that was really motivating me to work
out
was when i had my class pass like i
absolutely loved going to different
classes
and getting to try out new activities
but with an instructor i miss
that all right oh you know i'm still
wearing my glasses
these are my computer glasses they got
like protective uh
they have protective stuff hey tiff what
is the computer glasses
uh protecting blue light ah thank you
isaac
now we're outside now i should probably
put on sunglasses to protect myself from
uv light what are we doing out here
isaac
are you peeing no i'm drowning
oh yeah yeah this guy died huh yeah our
hoa is not doing a good job at keeping
our plants alive
or i've been learning a lot about
keeping plants alive lately key
component to keeping plants alive
are to check your soil and if your soil
feels wet
that means there's still a little bit of
something for your plants to feast on
they're all still kind of moist and the
last time we uh watered those is like
two or three days ago now apparently our
hoa does not know that
and they're literally killing our our
plants on the outside
should i just take over the
responsibility of watering the plants
and stuff and just making sure they live
or maybe i should write an
angry email and be one of those types of
people carrying my way
through the hoa and be like hey watering
my plants or something how do you like
the water pressure thingy pretty fun
yeah fun to mess with fun to
wash with what you play with i see
we are washing cars right now and i'm
gonna pull my car around i'm being
attacked
i'm being attacked i've been attacked
[Music]
damn that looks really fun actually i
kind of want to do it too all right
so what's the go-to method of washing
cars for you
what have you i sweat the entire car
with the entire car
yep maybe we work faster right yup i wet
the entire car
and then after i put in the soap
been playing too much fortnite which is
very satisfying it's very satisfying
and it's a easy way to spread it instead
of wasting a lot of
soap just doing like that oh i see i see
so our approach to having isaac uh wash
cars is to
you know we kind of gave isaac the basic
gist of how to wash a car
section by section like one side of the
car wash
and then wash the other side because
otherwise especially
some hot summer days it's gonna dry your
car if you're gonna like soak the entire
car or whatever
try not to give him too much information
like
too many specifics because i didn't want
to dictate on
his own ability to formulate his own
like
methods and stuff like methodology or
whatever so
i'm gonna follow his program we're gonna
we're gonna wash the car
and i just gonna lead the way here we go
oh by the way
we got rid of a lot of the furniture
back here in the garage
just got this big couch that won't sell
for whatever reasons couches are not
in currently i sold all the tables
everything else just the couch it's very
hard to sell i don't know why
[Music]
car is looking pretty good isaac's
vacuuming inside now
how you feeling you look tired i'm very
tired
yeah and mom wanted me to do her car oh
yeah
that's not going to be the day huh oh
okay
i personally don't really like it but
this is like the best way to make money
oh yeah chores yeah every time
i tell myself we're not going to wash
the car today like
like next time i'm not washing cars and
then i forget how
painful it is i'm being a baby being a
baby
no i actually like washing cars yeah uh
it's just very tiring and it puts me in
a bratty mood
oh like a lazy mood yeah i know what you
mean
it's tough work tough work yet it's life
and uh one day when you actually get
your first job you're gonna feel that
way about that first stop too
so this is a nice little precursor so
you kind of know what you're
you're in for for the rest of your life
all right now this suite over here
is driving me nuts it's taking all the
life of this bush
this shrub here so this is what i want
and to save
hope i can save it actually it looks
really dead
and this is the culprit right here and
i'm gonna destroy
this guy
and that was easy destroyed
all right just got off the grocery store
at h mart try to find if you have an h
mart around you because that is hands
down the best asian grocery store you
can find
i am loving my car it's super super
clean thank you isaac for washing my car
and uh hopefully tiff will get her car
washed
tomorrow i know isaac was really really
tired isaac is at the age where
he thinks that if he is a busybody and
just you know exerts a lot of energy
and a lot of movement that there will be
progress and i
i had to spend some time telling him
that you know just because you're moving
a lot doesn't mean you're actually
getting anything done
hopefully when he washes his car he
won't be so tired afterwards and
uh and yeah maybe he'll be able to watch
two cars in one day but i found it
really really endearing that he uh
did he gives it his all every time why
am i still wearing this
uh it's so hard to breathe sometimes so
it's really cool to see him grow up and
try to take responsibility
and and and earn his money his chores
and so
now heading home got some groceries
we're doing some korean barbecue
and joe recently gave us a korean
barbecue grill
a good grill that you can do at home and
i've always avoided buying one of these
because
if you've seen in the last video where
we're baking with julia
i have really sensitive smoke detectors
and it always gets triggered whenever
we're baking anything that needs to be
like charred or
roasting things inside the oven
especially from stir frying and it needs
to just get that little smoke going on
it gets triggered so korean bbq for sure
is a no-go so
it's never something we want to do but
now that we have our backyard set up
we're going to try and do some korean
barbecue in our backyard a beautiful
backyard i can't wait and i'm getting
hungry i got some kimchi
some seasoned seaweed this
is one of my favorite ice creams uh
desserts
frozen desserts it is a ice cream pastry
with some strawberry in there and some
vanilla ice cream now this is something
new this is uh i've never
tried this boiled pork [ __ ] not
something that you would think would be
delicious right off the bat
but i'm an adventurous eater and i'm
willing to try anything
and it caught my eye today so we'll give
that a try today
got some seasoned fresh cucumber tiff's
favorite
some seasoned green bean sprouts top
blade
flat iron steak everybody's favorite
lots and lots of briskets you can't do
korean barbecue correct without
some pork belly as well so bam
this is definitely more than one night's
worth of korean bbq by the way i
actually wish they could package
korean bbq meats in like little like
one-night sets
like a little bit of brisket a little
bit of pork belly and kind of like
you know make little sets whereas like
i mean i'm buying if i want pork belly
i'm buying one two three four five six
seven eight
strips of pork butt that's way too much
i actually want to try this one
boiled meat
smells like meat hmm oh
simple which is really really salty
korean cold cuts
this would make for a bomb sandwich
actually don't spoil my dinner
so if you guys can see the latest
whoa what is this is that how it powers
joe
was giving away all his belongings
because he stashed everything
at the office um because he recently
moved in with and christina
he has no use for any of his stuff and
so he decided to just
start giving things out and so i was
quick to raise my hand for a korean
barbecue grill because it's something
i've always wanted
check it out this is the beauty right
here but this is interesting this is the
power
thingy goes in here yep and it goes and
then
we probably need an extension cord
though got the grease trap in there
cool oh okay this is how you take it
apart
or not i don't know all right i just
unplugged this guy because i realized it
was
it was that that was preventing it from
being lifted up so this is the grill
the grates i mean and then obviously all
the juices and oils would drip through
these holes
and into this drip pan pretty cool oh my
goodness easy cleaning
yes this is what i'm talking about thank
you so much joe
all right it is dinner time now i'm
super excited
all right here we go magic time bam
bam all right we got the grill heating
up you ready for some korean barbecue
when's the last time we had korean
barbecue
since before uh we used to frequent
korean bbq
a lot it's something that we just really
really miss and
we haven't had a chance to try the
outdoor korean barbecue spots because
now that a lot of
restaurants are ready to reopen we
haven't really gone out to a whole lot
of restaurants
actually you know what i don't i can i
think i've only been to
two restaurants but korean bbq is not
one of those this is cool
i know are you guys ready to begin
[Music]
now be careful this thing's already hot
okay i forgot to take these off
you look so cute with that one though
yes you get four eye diff bone apple tea
bone apple tv three two one
[Music]
you know i've been gaining weight so
i've been gaining so much weight that my
pants are getting tighter and they're so
tight that they're pressing the buttons
on my keyboard
why do you have your keys in your pocket
at least i know my car is locked oh you
didn't get the brown sauce
that's the best part about korean
barbecue sauce oh man
what's the sesame oil i like the brown
sauce
[Music]
you got some maggi sauce
[Music]
maggie's good but
i don't know i don't know about this
[Music]
now we can do corner barbecue any time i
want that
thanks joe thank you joe thank you so
much
[Music]
me